joining the Nights Watch or taking the
black is a singular honor for any
northerner for it was in the north some
8,000 years ago that the first man drove
back the White Walkers erected the wall
and established the sworn Brotherhood
that would guard the realm and its
people from the dangers beyond
regrettably the Nights Watch no longer
commands the widespread respect and
admiration it once did while House Stark
and other houses and the northern
regions continued to recognize its vital
importance to the safety and stability
of the realm this view is not shared by
the powerful houses of the southern
kingdoms nor their subjects most regard
the watch as a misguided obsolete order
made up of useless outcasts admittedly
the current Nights Watch is a shadow of
its former glory their numbers have
dwindled to less than a thousand of the
19 castles along the war only three are
functional the shadow tower Castle black
and eastwatch-by-the-sea and the watch's
mandate of adding to the wall has been
abandoned entirely there are barely
enough resources to maintain it
recruiting officers known as wandering
crows scour the dungeons and slums of
the realm in hope of finding men to fill
the ranks while there is still the
occasional highborn volunteer the newest
recruits are almost entirely made up of
lowly criminals thieves rapists and
murderers sentenced to the wall as
punishment for their crimes the decline
of this once fabled order is troubling
as the danger of cards against is all
too real while the White Walkers haven't
been seen nor heard from in ages and may
very well be the stuff of myth barbarian
tribes that well beyond the wall
Nola's wildlings have been a menace to
the north and its people for generations
at certain points in history the
disparate wildling tribes have united
behind a single leader and King beyond
the wall and attempted large-scale
attacks against the role but thanks to
the resourceful and courageous man of
the Nights Watch these so-called Kings
were soundly defeated while many have
lost faith in the Nights Watch the
people of the north are steadfast in
their belief that the black brothers
will answer the call of duty but with
winter coming diminished numbers and a
lack of widespread support will they be
ready